добрий день дякую всім хто прийшов наш
basic у нас дуже коротке повідомлення на та
що дуже важливо і 7 травня цього року.
днів тому в ефірі ток-шоу свобода слова
відомий журналіст Дмитро Гордон
випустив на волю деякі слова
які мають бути наслідком
саме він заявив
і зробив це формі твердження що 5
президент України порошенко вступив до
злочинні угоди з путіним та
наказав у рамках цього злочинного
угоди української армії особливо
залишити морю у дмитрія гордона з
давня історія його коментарів з
щодо політики 5 президенти ніхто не
залишить його права не любити порошенка та
говорити про це але коли мова заходить про
зловживання свободи слова і про те
що будь-який наклеп якщо він
супроводжується словами я вважаю це моє
думка а далі йде не думка
твердження користуються абсолютний салют
імунітетом це не так ми анонсуємо що
найближчим часом найближчими днями як тільки
будуть виконані всі необхідні
формальності буде потім 1
такого роду позов сторони Петра Порошенка
від імені Петра Порошенка до Гордону
з вимогою визнати недостовірними
влаштовують народження ось витя гордон
буде можливість висловитися з цього
з приводу якщо він вважаю що ти все-таки
думка вони затвердження некритичне
твердження він може про це сказати що
він не знає про це сам він так думає
у нього буде можливим запросимо його до
цьому
повідомити такі докази якщо
вони є я думаю що їх немає та
твердження так інакше буде можливість
порозуміється не фармація
мало до чого зобов'язує ток-шоу форматі
формалізовану цю процедуру
це до цього давно що він мабуть томмен
нас там ми вибрали такий спосіб повідомити
про це публічно тому що гордон
є публічною особою питання свободи
слова це важливе питання і я за
вживання свобода слова це складова
частина
я в це потрібно говорити сук я вважаю що
в короткій і ми дочекаємося коментарів по
з цього приводу найближчими тижнями хто кого
закінчену всі формальності dmitry
зможе прокоментувати чи його юристи
які будуть обстоювати зможуть
коментувати в заяві і далі
продовжувати формально причому